the U.S Administration is urging Israel
to restore Janine refugee camps
infrastructure after its two-day assault
that killed 12 Palestinians the White
House says it's critical to rebuild the
massive damage caused the Palestinian
Authority estimates reconstruction will
cost around 15 and a half million
dollars Palestinians have been returning
to their home with many uninhabitable
let's go live to Janine where Nita
Ibrahim is standing by for us near that
two days on from this Israeli raid has
the likes of Power and Water and any
critical infrastructure been restored
yet
this is too early at this point as far
as officials tell us the water the
electricity all of these things will
take time they've put up the officials
here an emergency plan to restore some
of it a little bit of water here and
there small power here and there as well
but we're talking about an operation of
restoration that the Palestinian
Authority cannot afford to take care of
so basically they're trying to secure
what they can from the International
Community to be able to build up the
roads the infrastructures you can see
the entrance of the refugee camp this is
one of the entrances it's filled with
the rubble that the trucks have been
collecting from inside the camp we're
seeing some families returning there's
still the damage is very very clear here
you can see the homes that have been
partially demolished the effects and the
aftermath of the shooting people took
more now not just about the physical
damages but really they want the world
to know that it has been a traumatic
experience for them and for their
children there's a lot of fear here
remember this refugee camp used to be
the place where fighters from
practically and and let's say safe in
some way for the fighters to come there
now Netanyahu says that this operation
is not the first and it's not going to
be the last so there's a lot of tension
here as to how would that mean in terms
of the equation that was uh worked by
let's say for the past a year or so
whereby this was kind of the safe haven
for Fighters elsewhere in the occupied
West Bank so we've been talking to
Fighters here they say they're not going
to cave in and they're going to continue
the fight
all right thanks so much for the update
Nita Ibrahim ingine for us